I want to see like how does who you call
how did you who do you how do you call
an agency so I started I started just
making all these different lists and
ideas of what I wanted to do and then I
contacted other girls that were in the
industry so it kind of had an idea of
what I should expect to get paid and
what companies to avoid and then I
started just going on different message
boards and sort of gathering the same
information so I had a list of people to
avoid 100% and then a list of agencies
so I emailed four or five different
agencies nobody I think one maybe
emailed me back and then they were like
hard to actually get on the phone I and
this is 2006 so not everybody has
smartphones for me if you can pick up
the phone and call that's a big deal and
the first person who actually called me
was the one agent that I ended up
working with and he called me and he
goes yeah if you really look like this
you're gonna make it far you got your
own car yeah okay great okay so what I
did I guess I I did all of that
like quasi research for six months or so
and then I ended up driving down to LA
for a week to look for an apartment and
then in that time I was hoping oh and
this week I'll find an agent how hard is
it and during that week nobody called me
only the one email and actually on my
way home back to Sacramento he was
driving home that's when I got that
phone call so I was like well I'll be
back in a week I'm actually moving here
Wow
now the what was that do you remember
the first scene you did yeah
was you nervous I was and it was it was
that hurry-up-and-wait feeling
right so it was also an orgy so at first
it's like [ __ ] this is this is it and I
had the entire day to change my mind you
know waiting so and I hated that wait
that that period of having to wait and
at first it's it felt that that would be
the most intimidating kind of scene to
do especially for your first scene but
then once I was actually in it and
[ __ ] it was actually the best because
I was working with one of the most
respected directors in the industry and
with all of the top talent so being
there I felt like okay the pressure is
actually not on me yeah it's and I can
kind of ride on on on the other people
because they're more experienced so I
can just watch observe and see how it
goes and it actually ended up probably
being a really great experience and then
my agent came on set and then at that
point night was like it's all downhill
from here kid basically it's like me
being just a young actor and getting
like Ocean's eleven is my first thing
yeah that's basically was like oh
there's Brad Pitt and Method that's what
your situation basically yeah Wow
Rocko is the first so um if I threat now
you since you're out of the business if
I could throw it through some companies
your way can you tell me if you like
them or not or no like ones like I like
red light district are they good they
have good benefits are they good
I don't know them did you work for
red-light district yeah
do you like though yeah yeah yeah I like
that company yeah yeah I think in a
different life if comedy didn't work out
for you I feel like you would have been
an agent of sorts or a foreign agent for
adult I would know I would have my own
production company I would have I would
be like a devil's film